have you ever been in twitch chat and
noticed people spamming this name and
wondered who the f is Clara Clara what
the did I tell you by using my computer
back in 2017 a small streamer named Miss
Q Gemini was playing some competitive
Inferno when all of a sudden weird
outlines of enemy players started
showing up on her screen and as we know
only one person could be responsible for
such
Shenanigans wait what the Clara hold on
Clara she was at my house earlier today
what the actual in reality this was
obviously no accident trying to pass it
off on someone else using your PC is a
clever idea and it might have worked if
she didn't literally stream herself
turning the hacks on now is Clara a
sister a friend a ghostly Apparition who
knows but thanks to this ridiculous
situation Clara instantly became a meme
used whenever someone pulled off a VW
worthy play or just generally suspicious
Behavior
GL